And I want to welcome you to a very special topic. And the topic is a movie analysis about The Matrix, the movie from 1999, from back then the Wachowski brothers. And I've been asked about The Matrix and do an analysis on that for a very long time.
And I was afraid to do it, not because I thought I could not, but rather because The Matrix is a kind of movie that had so much analysis and so many things were said about it that I thought, okay, I, I cannot find an angle which is kind of new. I could not say anything that would be not something that already someone else has said it and likely said it better.
That changed a little bit because we did a little analysis of a short movie from the Animatrix. Anthology roughly half a year ago, which was really, really cool. It's an 8-minute short movie and it's animated.
And I think we talked about it 3 or 3 and a half hours in the group, and there were really good ideas from the people that participated. And this was a really good discussion. And I think I found there's some, some angle into the movie that I hope no one else has found. At least in this depth. And this is why I want to now talk about The Matrix.
So basically people here made it possible. I also watched the movie again just now recently as preparation, and I had Stefan helping me out there a lot as he's also a writer. And yeah, so The Matrix. And I will ignore most analysis and I hope like I have some original things in there.
The interesting thing is about The Matrix that you can talk about it really a lot. There's a lot of, let's say, philosophical questions posed there. And I think this is the reason why people are still talking about it. It's a question about like, do human beings need to suffer to exist? Can they accept happiness or paradise? What is freedom? What is free will?
Are human beings like a virus? So it also questions reality and the world that we live in and technology and progress and all these different things. And I think this is why this still captures the imagination of people, even though that the movie is now 25 years old. So it's not even from this century. It's not even from this millennia.
It's from the past millennia, like the very cusp of Changing of the Millennium. And I chose the subtitle for this as Knowing is Believing for a very specific reason, because of the concept of gnosis.
And gnosis is very well encapsulated in the quote from the movie, the exchange between Neo and Trinity when they meet for the first time, where Neo asks like, what is The Matrix? And Trinity says, about Morpheus, when I asked him, he said that no one could ever be told the answer to that question. They have to see to believe it.
And that reminded me of another quote, a very famous quote from Jung. And this is from a BBC interview where he was asked whether he believes in God. And the answer he gave was, I don't need to believe. I know. And we did a discussion about this interview already some time ago, and it was also a very, very good discussion.
And this opens up a lot of questions like, okay, how can you not believe in God, but rather say like, you know, and the concept that's behind that is the concept of gnosis, which means knowledge is from ancient Greek.
And it refers to direct experiential knowledge and that it does more, like it's more about a transformation. It's about what it does to the person to know something similar as, for example, knowing that there's a God or knowing that there's The Matrix. And there's a whole, let's say, philosophy behind it. And the philosophy is called Gnosticism.
And I have a quote here from Jung for that, which goes: The Gnostics held that this god was a vain inferior demon who in his vanity had created man imperfect and unconscious, and that therefore it was a mighty good thing when the foreign god of the spiritual worlds interfered with the doings of that creator and sent his son into paradise in the form of the serpent to redeem man, to teach him consciousness.
So the redemption was simply the continuation of the separation. The distinction, the separation was then understood as a good thing inasmuch as it was a separation from something that was evil. They understood it from the side of individuation. So there's already a lot of stuff in here. So the Gnostics are really old, they're almost 2,000 years old.
They posed a specific question. They asked, okay, if God is perfect, then why did he create the world so imperfectly? Why is there suffering? Why is like bad things happening? So they had the idea that not God the creator created the world, but rather like a lesser being, the Demiurge.
And the Demiurge created an incomplete world, a corrupted world in a sense. So it is kind of vital to wake up from that world, to realize it, and to free oneself in a way from it. So the stories in the Bible become a completely different meaning.
Like in the traditional sense, when you have Genesis and Adam and Eve get expelled from paradise, this is seen like, oh, this is the mortal sin of humans and they sinned against God and now they have to toil in the world. And labor under sweat and blood for their daily bread and all these different things.
And that the snake is associated with Satan that tempted Eve and Adam into being expelled from paradise. And the Gnostics say, no, no, no, well, the world is wrong. So knowledge and consciousness is a good thing. And actually the snake is the savior, which is a very interesting thought. And you could believe this is heresy.
We don't have so much left from the Gnostics. Most of it got destroyed, but we have some fragments left and we have elaborations from the church about the Gnostics. And the thing is, like, you cannot really keep ideas down. Things are popping up. And this is what this event will be about.
It's about, there's certain ideas that come up again and again and again, and they get kind of re-explored. New and new and new, because this is what human beings do and how they experience the world. So we will go through these points here.
We will go through the thing there, the creature that brings consciousness, and we will go through individuation and how much it actually fits for The Matrix. So the question is, what makes a story Gnostic? Like, how did that come to this point to say like, oh yeah, this is a Gnostic story. And there's some points for that.
So for example, that the world is a prison or an illusion, similar to the cave in Plato's allegory, where people are watching the shadows on the wall thinking that's a real thing, but the philosopher breaks out, sees the sun, sees the truth and says like, oh, that's a false light there in the cave and tries to free people from that.
There's a hidden ruler or false god in this world that keeps up this illusion. And the hero, so the main figure for the story, has an existential discomfort about how things are. They're feeling that there's something wrong and they feel out of place and they say, okay, there's something not right, something that needs to be rectified.
And the salvation happens through knowledge and an internal awakening to become aware of the world and how it really is. And get transformed in the process of that.
And what we have here on the right is a really old and famous picture from the Middle Ages showing like how people break out of the world, this world that they see and which is kind of a world of illusion to see beyond this, to see the, the greater thing, the, let's say the real world.
And this as a story concept might already pop up some ideas in your mind that reminds you of certain stories. And it was a very, very, very popular topic around the shifts of the millennia. And you had such movies as The Truman Show or Pleasantville or Dark City or 13th Floor.
And also really a lot of stories from Philip K. Dick revolve around these ideas, these Gnostic ideas that fit this description as it described here, up to the point that when Matrix came out, that it got sued a lot. Like a lot of people said, hey, wait, this, this is my idea. People are living in a situation and they're trying to free themselves.
There were some lawsuits that are still going on actually about how much the Wachowski brothers stole. And then it's a question, okay, how much is actually like stealing, taking things, and how much is coming from, let's say, the same source. Because Jung says, we in our psyche, we have a collective unconscious.
That's a layer of psychology, which is common to all human beings as they exist now, as they existed in the past and how they will exist in the future. And when we do creative work, we draw from that source. It's not only that we draw from this source, but this is also The things that people like the most.
So when something is very popular and it speaks to a lot of people, it's archetypal. This is why we have love songs or horror stories and all these different things.
Jung sees there an entanglement between our psychology and the cultural artifacts or creations that we have in our culture, in our life, and that we like to experience because it's in a way experiencing our own psyche. It speaks to us. It's reaching into us and it's activating something.
So it is that The Matrix on the one side is an amalgamation about a lot of things. As the screenwriters wrote about it 10 years, they wrote on the script for 10 years and nobody wanted to do it because When you read it, it's like already pretty expensive with all the special effects and so on, but it was also a very wild idea and they were unproven.
They only had one movie before, it was called Bound. And, but this gave them time to like work through it again and again and again and again and incorporate really a lot of influences that they had and that they experienced around this time, this Zeitgeist. So this collective spirit of the time. That captured people in their imagination.
This also explains why the first Matrix movie was so good with amazing lore, amazing ideas and worldbuilding, all these different things. And the second Matrix movie was not quite up to the task because it did not have so much time. That is how it is in Hollywood. If you want to make money, you have to make it quick. So let's talk about the serpent.
Let's talk about the figure that appears and brings consciousness to the unconscious creatures in this false prison world. And in the story, that's Morpheus. And of course, I have some quotes about that from Jung.
The inner voice, as I have explained above, makes us conscious of the evil from which the whole community is suffering, whether it be the nation or the whole human race. The voice that Jung is talking about is the psychological concept of the Self. Jung says we are not alone in our psyche.
We have a very complex psychological apparatus as human beings that is kind of in different layers so that we have our consciousness, we have our personal unconscious, and we have our collective unconscious. But those are not dead layers. Those are not just like places where you go, but those are living, breathing things that can also interact with you.
And he says one central concept within this psychological structure is the self. And the self is a kind of combination of everything which is in the psyche. You can think about it as a kind of future you. So when you have, for example, have an acorn, the tree is already in the acorn. You cannot see it. Right? But it unfolds over time.
And the Jungian view is on it that the tree calls out to the acorn to let it grow in a certain way. So the psychological development of, of us as human beings, as individuals, as persons, is that there is a psychological force within us.
That is kind of steering us in a certain direction and it's guiding us in a certain way. He says there's a lot of voices and there are a lot of things trying to steer us, but there's, for example, emotions or archetypes and all these different things.
But he says like, yeah, like one of those voices is actually on our side and that this is also the basis for a lot of religious experiences and religions that there is this voice calling to us. Socrates had something similar with his daemon. And in the movie, this is exemplified by Morpheus.
He represents the Self for Neo as the main character, and he speaks to Neo. He's that voice. And how does that voice come? Through text on a screen, through a telephone. So completely disembodied. Voice that is there, then this is not only represented with Morpheus for the first time.
This has been represented very often in human history. And for the alchemists, for example, this was through Mercurius, the Greek messenger of the gods. And this is why Sean Connery is here. Also represented very often as an old man, for example, Gandalf in Lord of the Rings. So this is what Jung talks about here.
Archetype of the old man. Whenever he appears, he also refers to a certain situation. There's some disorientation, a certain unconsciousness. People are in a sort of confusion and don't know what to do. It is this voice.
That's represented by Morpheus, that we can say like, when we have a cultural creation as a theater play, book, or even a drawing, like anything, that Jung says this is our psyche expressing itself, which means we have there externalized a lot of things that are happening inside of us, like a theater, like a play.
So to have then the interaction between Morpheus and Neo is the interaction between the Self and, let's say, the individual consciousness of ego. And what Morpheus does in this story is to bring people into consciousness, similar as the snake in the Gnostic text, bringing people out of paradise, out of their unconsciousness.
And interestingly enough, what does Morpheus wear in the movie? He wears a leather coat. In a snakeskin, which is quite interesting. Of course, he does not only do it to Neo. He also does it to a bunch of other characters.
The characters being Cypher and in an indirect way also Agent Smith. The problem with consciousness is The thing that, let's say, makes us human creates also a lot of suffering. Like being aware of things and paying attention to things means that you also not pay attention to other things.
And a big part of growing up is becoming, let's say, aware of the suffering of the world and how incomplete the world is, or even worse, how incomplete oneself is. And you have Cypher that got the call from the Self, from Morpheus, about the truth and the real world and got the choice to learn about it. And he learned about it and he wants to go back.
And this is how he's willing to betray not only his immediate friends, but let's say the possibility of human beings to get out of the Matrix because Morpheus is the way how to do that. And this is what this quote is fitting very, very well for. We believe that mentally ill persons aren't happy. Not at all.
They don't want to get out at all. I once treated someone. She was in it too. I got her out using all the tricks of the trade. She explained to me, now you've got me out of here into this filthy world. I don't want to be here. Now I can't go back. You see, I had locked the door behind her, but she would much rather have been insane. And this is a situation of Cypher.
He's negotiating with the agents to go back because he wants the illusions. He wants the fakeness. He does not want to be confronted with the real world and all the things that are associated with that. He rather wants to be asleep. He does not want to be awake. And absolutely interestingly enough, that's also the motivation for Agent Smith.
This is what he tells Morpheus, so the Self, during the interrogation scene. He says he cannot stand this human world. He cannot stand everything about it. Like, he's a computer program, but he has to go in this kind of mortal world and be bound by the rules of it and experience it, and says he's sick and tired of it.
He wants his job done, and this is why he wants the codes to Zion, so he can end the whole charade. The agents are there to hunt down the human beings that are awake. So they have a task, they have a goal, and they have to bring them down. Until they bring them down, they have to be kind of conscious. They have to be also kind of outside the program itself.
You see that with Agent Smith having his own thoughts, his own ideas. And going also his own way. In a sense, Morpheus also made him conscious about the Matrix, but he doesn't want that. And this reminded me of something that I've seen in Rick and Morty, which is this figure of Mr. Meeseeks, which is also a very good analogy to consciousness and how consciousness works.
Like Jung said, the best way to become conscious of a thing is to hit your head. Consciousness is there to mitigate a problem. So you live your life, you do it normally, you drive a car, you're in a relationship, you use your computer, and suddenly something acts up, something does not work.
So you become jolted awake, and now you are kind of confused and you have to figure stuff out. And this is like very, very tiring. This can be very, very tiring and scary. And a lot of things, can happen. Like, ah, I would rather not have this problem. But the question is what to do. The thing is the problem needs to be confronted.
And similarly, in Rick and Morty, the figure of Mr. Meeseeks, they have to do things and solve things. Like for example, Meeseeks gets the task, bring me a beer. So it comes into existence, brings the beer, and then disappears. And in the episode, they have to teach Jerry, a character in the show How to Golf, and he's just so bad at it that he does not learn how to golf.
So Mr. Meeseeks just stays awake, awake, awake, awake, and he says like, this is existence is pain. Like, I just want to go back. And this is what is then with Agent Smith, who's kind of representing an evil spirit that pops up in the psyche.
Jung talks about autonomous psychological forces in the psyche of people that comes up and brings people to do something. And you see that in the movie, like people turn into Agent Smith, they become kind of activated. And Jung sees this also with complexes or archetypes or emotions that people suddenly become very impersonal.
Emotions are not personal. Emotions are not you. Like anger, lust, sadness. That's not the human person. It's in the sphere of human experience, but it can completely take people over. Like an idea, like an ideology, like fascism, communism, or many fanatic strains of religion. It's not about the individual person.
It's about more of a system that's trying to keep itself alive. Similar as Agent Smith. But Agent Smith, he wants to break out of the programming and he wants his existence ceased. Which brings us to the last character, which is important in the story, which is Trinity, like the right hand of Morpheus and the love interest for Neo.
And interestingly enough, I have a quote about her role in the movie. Also from Jung again: The old wise man represents the wisdom of the serpent, as the anima represents its movement and cunning.
There is really very little difference between the old wise man and the anima, and therefore the two are so often together, as in the myth of Simon Magus and Helena and the idea of the Sibyl or somnambule and the wise man. This was pronounced horribly.
But Jung says when you have your psyche, you go through kind of figures that you encounter representing the different parts of your psyche. The first one is the shadow, uh, which is the personal unconscious, which is kind of your personal problems that you have. And afterwards, you're confronted more with the collective. You're more confronted with fundamental things.
And like a fundamental thing in the psychology of a man as for example Neo, is his femininity, is his female side. And this represented in man is through the anima, a figure that represents their female side, but also more as it's connecting to the collective part of the psyche.
So it's an interesting, when you see it in the movie, it's an interesting that this is how stories get written and how people like to experience them. Because who does Neo encounter first? It's the anima. Similar as in Jungian psychology. Jung says, first you encounter shadow, then the anima, and then the Self. And the anima being basically the female side of the Self.
So it is Trinity that creates the contact and brings the Neo to Morpheus. Which is the Self. Which brings us to Neo and his journey. And his journey is that of individuation.
Individuation means becoming an individual, meaning being separated from things, which doesn't mean like completely separated from human relationships or the world or anything, or from emotions, but rather integrated. Aware and awake enough to realize that you are not the role that you play in society.
You are not the emotions that you have inside of you. You are not the thoughts that you have inside of you. That you're not identical with them and just act them out, let's say, but rather reflect on them and realize what is personal and what is not personal.
And this process is symbolically represented in the movie through like constant waking up If you pay attention to the, in the movie, there's a lot of scenes where Neo is just waking up. He's waking up when he looked at the monitor. He wakes up after they instill the, uh, like the robot in his belly button. And also he is waking up from the Matrix, right? In his pod.
And it is that the Self is showing Neo the way, but he always has to do the decision. He always have to. Make a choice which way to go. So this is what a lot of scenes in the beginning are about. Like he's asked, oh, you want to come to the party? And he follows the white rabbit to the party. His boss asks him whether he wants to keep his job or not.
And also then the interesting story, like when it's the first time contact with Morpheus and it's this disembodied voice coming, telling him what to do, trying to escape, having the superior knowledge about the situation. And the agents approaching him and say like, this is how you escape and this is what you have to do. Neo is not able to do it because he does not yet believe.
He does not yet know. He's not in this psychological frame of mind to follow those orders. And Jung says what the Self will pose to us, to the ego, will seem strange and foreign. Same as for Socrates, his Self, his daimon, For example, told him you need to play the flute and he could not play the flute, so he just started making a horrible thing out of it.
But it also told him to stay and not flee Athens, even though that he would be killed for that. And this is one of the big reasons why we know Socrates today, because he did not run. He listened to his inner voice.
So the individuation process has to do with separation from things and like one way to break free from the collective, the collectiveness, is through a secret society. And human beings really, really, really like secret societies with secret knowledge and mysteries and all these different things. So the secret society is an intermediary stage on the way to individuation.
The individual is still relying on a collective organization to affect his differentiation for him. That is, he has not yet recognized that it is really the individual's task to differentiate himself from all the others and stand on his own feet. And this is what's happening to Neo. Neo is being introduced into a new society, into a new world. And this is the resistance.
This is Morpheus and his team of the Nebuchadnezzar. So he's learning there new things, the way how to do and how to behave. For example, don't fight the agents. Run away.
And Neo follows that, but even though that Morpheus is showing him the way and he has to make the choices and being active about it, individuation is always about action, it's still not enough. He has to kind of transcend also that.
And this is then when he kind of goes against the secret society when he wants to save Morpheus and say like, no, I want to save him. I want to confront the agents. And everybody's saying, ah, this is madness. This is absolutely crazy. And he says, ah, no, I know it will work out. Just, I have to do it.
And this is then the interesting point in the story because Morpheus as a figure, as a guiding light, kind of disappears. Now Neo has to stand on his own feet. And this relationship is very similar to what Jung described between a therapist and a patient.
So when a patient would come to Jung describing the problems of their lives, Jung said he would take a kind of helpful position of this inner voice that people have inside of them with a goal that this contact, this connection to the inner voice is reestablished.
That people don't want to stay in Wonderland and kind of ignore the things that are going on, but rather pay attention to that and follow that. And this is what he describes here. All of us have our best analyst within ourselves, and therefore I try to bring forth his inner voice in everyone that I treat, which then replaces me. I can leave.
The voice does everything in my place. So there is a kind of structure and harmony within the psyche, which can be broken, but also reestablished. And this is then what's symbolized also in the story of The Matrix. So Neo does this.
Neo follows the voice of the Self, acts on his own feet, makes his own decisions. And shows that an alternative way of living is possible. Like even to the people who are awake from the Matrix and know like everything, even they are made aware like, okay, you can confront the agents. You can put up a fight.
So it's interesting that their consciousness also gets expanded by Neo. Maybe that's why he is the one. But first, he's not the one. This is what he's being told. And it's right. Like the way how Neo is, He is not the one. Like, he has a good heart, as the oracle says, but he has to do more, much more. And interestingly enough, again, this is a Gnostic idea.
And this is what this quote is about. The Gnostic idea of Christ was that he was not born a Christ. He had to be a twice-born, baptized in the Jordan, in order to become the real God-Christ.
According to this tradition, The Holy Ghost generated the body of the man Christ by the miraculous impregnation of the Virgin, but he was still only an ordinary man, though his generation was a miracle. So Neo has to become the one, and he has to die to be reborn then into the one, the savior of the human race, the one that Morpheus has been looking for.
So he becomes transformed and transfigured. And there's another tradition in the West that deals with that, which is that of alchemy, that Jung also very closely investigated because of its psychological value. This is what this quote is about.
In the Middle Ages, philosophy—this means alchemy—prevailed over the fact that such an extent that the base metal lead was credited with the power to turn into gold under certain conditions. And the dark psychic man with the capacity to turn himself into a higher pneumatic man. But just as lead, which theoretically could become gold.
The idea in alchemy is really that the gold is already in the lead. It's a chemical process that brings forth something. There's a kind of spirit trapped in there. There's a spirit trapped in matter, and the material world that needs to be set free by human beings. And the alchemist does this through himself, through changing himself.
He transforms the lead into gold, which is a symbolic representation showing like psychological transformation in Jung's eyes. But this is a similar story with Neo, right? He's a normal everyday man at the beginning. Has a job, is a hacker at night, and then he becomes the savior of the human race, but only because he goes the way of individuation and he is then reborn.
And a very, very interesting idea there is that Trinity kisses him at the right point, like his anima, also by Jung described as a soul image, reawakens him. And believes in him. And when I saw this, I was reminded by a quote from Robert A. Johnson in a book that he wrote.
I think it was He, that had to do with the interplay between masculinity and femininity. And he described like how, like little femininity the masculine needs to become, let's say, awake and to complete. And he said like that women have absolutely no idea how little femininity a man needs to really feel fulfilled.
And it's there and then that Trinity kisses Neo and he becomes awake. He becomes the one. It's like the last little push. He's dead on all accounts, but gets reinvigorated by his anima, his soul image. And there he becomes a synergy of the human world and the computer world, of the robot world.
He's able to see the code of the matrix, and he's not only a human being anymore. He can find the agents, and that's with ease now. And this is interesting because you have a lot of fairy tales or a lot of stories work like that.
You have a protagonist and you have an antagonist, and it's this journey for the protagonist, for the hero, to become like the antagonist, the, um, villain.
So Neo has to learn how to fight like an agent, and similar, Luke Skywalker needs to learn how to fight like Darth Vader to become a Jedi Knight, to learn all the tricks of the trade, to become like the evil thing but incorporate it together and bring like both worlds together. And you see it already in the kind of clothing that they're wearing and the, and the sunglasses.
They, they look like agents. The resistance, and they behave in a similar way, and they get also programmed. They have these programs run into their consciousness. They're being programmed like a computer, which is really interesting there, there to see. And the good thing, the very good thing about Neo is, and maybe this is a reason why he's the one, he does not get inflated.
Inflation in the Jungian sense means that people get possessed by a certain archetype or idea, and they completely get gripped by that. There are people that are convinced that they're the second coming of Jesus, that they're a great important man for world history, and humanity has waited for them. And their conviction is real.
Whether that's really the case, different story. But Neo stays very, very, very humble for the fact that He's the savior of the human race. So we will look in The Matrix and The Matrix as a system, and it is a very psychological movie, and we see a lot of psychological phenomena there.
And like one fundamental concept and idea of psychoanalysis and analytical psychology, which is a kind of brand of Jung in regards to psychology is that there are these unconscious forces, impersonal, autonomous, unconscious forces acting within oneself and acting through oneself.
And this is what this quote is about. It is intensely disagreeable to feel that one is not master in one's own house. It is like a defeat. So when one discovers a possession, there's a fear about possible events. Anything may happen then. That is the reason why we prefer to deny the possession, even if we know it. It goes back to this idea of Cypher.
Like, you learn something about the world, you learn something about yourself, you learn something about your psychology. The question is whether you accept it or not, whether you confront it or not. And it's very easy to say like, ah, no, I did not say that. I did not do that. Hmm. No, nothing unusual about me.
Even though that emotions, thoughts, ideas, archetypes might be acting through one and taking hold because it's too scary. It's too scary to realize that one is not alone in one's head and one is not master in his own house. But Jung goes further, and this is then where I think like, okay, there's really a Jung quote for everything. He talks about machines.
So The Matrix is a system of machines and programming, and Jung dealt really a lot with modernity and what modernity does to us psychologically-wise and how human beings are in a modern society, very different than before with new unique problems. And this is what this quote is about.
The machines which we have invented, for instance, are now our masters. Machines are running away with us. They are demons. They are like those huge old saurians that existed when man was a sort of lizard monkey and deadly afraid of their hooting and tooting. Monsters that crushed thousands by their voice and their weight.
And screw it, we're really dependent on machines and they're everywhere. And I'm talking to you through a machine right now. And then there's a question like, okay, how much are we the masters of the machine and how much machines masters of us. And I think like every year tilts a little bit more on the side of the machines.
But at the same time, we are human beings and we kind of have to fulfill their certain things. But I want to look at the psyche, at Matrix with psychological lens, and let's say treat the psyche as something that people become aware about their own psychology.
And especially becoming aware of the collective layer in their psychology, saying like, there's this ancient past within us where we are very similar to like all human beings and like these old eternal problems pop up again and again.
And even though that we live in the here and now with our own idiosyncratic lives, that there's a certain commonality there and incredibly strong forces coming up. So how is consciousness treated in the psyche? Actually, not that well. And Jung talks about that. Nature cannot stand ideas.
She's hostile to consciousness because it disturbs the great unconsciousness in which things glide along smoothly. Consciousness comes along and illuminates the darkness and upsets that smooth gliding movement of nature. So the powers of such movement are are all against illumination. Therefore, people in this situation have no time to listen or reflect.
They are too much caught by it, and they don't want to know what they are doing because of the fear of hearing something disagreeable. Nobody wants to know that they are in a movement which is going straight to hell. This goes back to this idea of possession and impersonal forces and Similarly, Carl Gustav Jung has a quote about that.
People don't have ideas, like we don't really have ideas or thoughts. Ideas have people. So this is that when you have collective movements such as ideologies of any kind, there's individuality lost and people are then entrenched in this psychological construct that's trying to keep itself alive to the detriment of people.
Why does somebody become a martyr? Why do they sacrifice themselves for a cause? Has nothing to do with them. It's about the idea. And this is what you can see then also in The Matrix. The Matrix tries to keep itself alive and tries to keep itself going. This is why it sends the agents to quell the consciousness, to quell light, because it's too upsetting.
Human beings have consciousness. And this creates a whole lot of problems. We can do a lot of things. We can do them willfully. Uh, we can also not do things willfully, which separates us a lot from animals because animals, they just do. Like, animals are not evil. They, they just exist. They do what they do.
But human beings, we can be evil because we can choose to do things or not do certain things. We have enough awareness. To really torture and punish people in the most cruel way possible because we are aware of our own psychology. So this is something there where consciousness is a difficult and dangerous thing.
And the question is then really, is The Matrix itself conscious or is it just like a natural product that reacts and lives? And Jung would say that like nature itself, if you look out, it's not conscious, it just acts and does.
And the collective part in our psyche is a natural part, like our human nature, and it acts and does certain things to us whether we agree with it or not. It, it happens and we have to accommodate. So everything that we see in The Matrix is incredibly psychological by the fact that it is humanity dreaming. We're in a kind of dream world, and this idea is not completely new.
A lot of things in The Matrix, they're coming from different sources or certain ideas that pop up. And one idea in the world where this is very prevalent is that in Indian philosophy, which is the concept of Maya, which is that it is illusionary world, that things are not as they seem.
And the idea goes even so far to say that Actually, the world that we have is a dream spun up of a god, and we are living in that dream. So The Matrix deals a lot with that also, with it, what is real, what is not real, because it's pretty clear that The Matrix is not real, but people behave like it. So they, they follow the rules because they expect it.
And as soon as they realize like, oh, actually this is not real, this is an illusion. Neo, for example, can bend the spoons. And Neo does then all these amazing things because he realizes, ah, things are not as what they seem. So then it's a question like, what is real? What is reality?
Is it what we see, what we experience, what we know, or something more, something that lies beyond that? This is like the basic questions about Gnosticism. And Jung says reality and real is what has an effect. So Even a dream is real in the sense of that it can affect us very much, like a psychological problem.
Even though when no one can see it from the outside, not directly, and cannot observe under a microscope, it's still real because it has an effect. It influences one. And in a similar way, one also has an influence by being able to affect things.
So The Matrix features then Like a ground of the movie, I mean, interpreting things like a dream, how we experience our own psyche in the dream. We don't necessarily go to a different place. We're going inside of us and experience then the different layers, the different figures, and interact with them.
And there we can see nature play out and showing us things, not with a purpose, but rather because it is as a kind of reaction. Jung sees the psyche as a homeostatic system that tries to create a balance. So if we go too far out with consciousness, there will be forces on the other side trying to catch up and gather, gather this back into, um, the fold.
And in The Matrix, we also have that, interestingly enough. And Jung has some quotes about that. So when we treat The Matrix, the movie, the world there as a dream, we can also interpret certain parts of this as dream symbolism. And Jung dealt really a lot with dreams and how to interpret those symbols.
He did not say, or did not like, let's say, dream books explained certain images or situations one has with a concrete meaning. But at the same time, he gave a lot of examples. So, and one has to do with the police.
When one sins against one's collective instinct, for instance, one's adaption to the collective conditions, one may be persecuted by a bull representing the herd instinct. The bull may even represent the police. Meaning there is something regulatory trying to get us back.
Into the herd, into an unconscious state, represented then through different symbols, just like the police or bull or other things that try to quell consciousness. And other symbols in dreams, which is also very interesting, are, for example, spiders or insects, crabs or octopus.
And Jung says it gets even so far, like the connection between our mind and our body and our psyche and the things that are happening that we might not be aware of, that dreaming of certain things could indicate certain bodily problems. There was a, for example, a patient of his who dreamt that he was bitten by a snake into his foot.
And then like half a year later, he got like a lame foot. So problem there. That he could see in the dream of people before they would turn schizophrenic, for example, or have other neurological conditions. So the sympathetic system, nervous system in this case, has its proper symbols.
It is symbolized by the invertebrate animals, not only the cold-blooded ones, spiders and other insects and crabs and octopus. Are all symbols for the sympathetic system. And what does the sympathetic nervous system do? It's responsible for the fight and flight mechanism.
So the similar thing that the resistance is trying to figure out in regards to the agents, that they run away from the agents and run away from the sentinels. Neo turns into a fight, a direct confrontation with those symbols, agents, forces of the unconscious.
And this is what he shows to the people of the resistance. And likely this is the reason why he's the one, because he can, he can do that. He can show that similar how Morpheus shows Neo how to behave. It's first Morpheus that confronts the agents and and fights them for the first time because of Neo.
Neo then follows Morpheus and does the same and shows others to do it. And this is then when, when Trinity shoots the agent on the top of the skyscraper. So the confrontation with the unconscious is for Jung an incredibly important step. So a lot of things look scary and strange because we do not contend with them.
And the psyche tries to recreate a homeostasis, a balance. And this is why something like a bull is following us. And what Jung says in this situation, we need to turn around and ask like, what do you want? Why are you coming after me? What am I missing? What I am not aware about, let's say. And this can be sent through the Self.
Trying to bring one into more complete human being. So it is, it is really interesting. It is really, really interesting. And to bring it then all together, this idea, like the Gnostics ideas, they are 2,000 years old.
Now we're talking about a movie that came out roughly 2,000 years later with The Matrix. And Jung kind of tracked the certain movements that happened in between that contended with similar ideas.
And especially about Gnosticism, he says, my enthusiasm was based on the discovery that the Gnostics were apparently the first thinkers in their own way to deal with the concepts of the so-called collective unconscious.
Gnosticism was a heretic view of the Christian religion where you have the same symbols, the same stories, but in different interpretative framework, which focused on individual revelation and like a very direct connection with God, which does not exist really in the Catholic Church.
You have to go through the church and through the Pope to God. Only the Pope speaks directly to God. And Gnosticism is like, oh no, well, it's an individual journey, let's say. So heresy, people get persecuted, stuff gets burned.
But this idea propagated forth because it's not only that a couple of people came up with it, but it reveals something true about human experience and the human journey and our psychology. And this is also where Jung sees that psychology comes up as a science. In the 20th century. It is very new science and a very new phenomenon.
We had similar things that kind of worked like psychology, but they were not named psychology. And psychology is a big, big topic today. This is why we all sit here together on a Wednesday afternoon. So psychology has often been exiled from official religions because it is awkward. So one finds there material of an extremely philosophic nature.
In our Christian world, for instance, you have the historical traditions of the Gnostics, which is a Hermetic philosophy, both early and medieval Gnosticism, and the Neo-Platonists. Plato again, like with the cave and also this idea of the prototypes and this ideal Pleroma world of ideal ideas.
And the later medieval philosophy in the form of alchemy and the Rosicrucians. And all of that, and even more, like when you have the Eastern philosophy and ideas, you have in The Matrix, you have in a movie, you have in a single story.
So it's really not a surprise that people are so interested in the movie and reflect on it because it touches a lot about fundamental things in the human psyche and the human experience.
This would conclude my talk about this story, this movie, and I hope you enjoyed and I hope you had fun and learned something. And yeah, now I'm very curious about all the déjà vus you had in your life and how they're connecting to The Matrix. So thank you.